[Music]
let's go to rose in my hometown
nashville tennessee what's up rose
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
thanks for calling what's in the world
is going on how can i help
i am a fairly new listener and i'm
hoping to get your advice welcome to our
game
you you almost doubled our listenership
that's so good
it's incredible yeah me and a few others
so what's up
i am 30 years old i am in an amazing
relationship i have a boyfriend of
nearly two years we're very very happy
last year
i was the victim
of a kidnapping robbery and sexual
assault oh my god and
um
i'm so sorry rose
thank you is that here in town
it was out of town so we moved
afterwards and
tried to
you know make nashville a new home yeah
um so it's been a journey and
i am very fortunate and grateful to
have found an amazing counselor that has
started
helping me on my healing journey
excellent and um
i was wondering how i can encourage my
boyfriend to seek counseling to help him
process this trauma for himself
yeah that's hard hard hard
first off what
if you're comfortable talking about it
what kind of paint me in context what
happened
sure sure so i um was a ride chair
driver and i was
picked up a passenger and um that
passenger was really volatile i didn't
know and
um held me at gunpoint and
just
for
you know throughout the evening just
forced me into situations i was
very traumatizing very uncomfortable
with and um
thankfully
i considered a miracle i survived i
didn't have a scratch on me i wasn't
shocked i wasn't beaten i wasn't
um
like physically
um
harmed in any way other than than the
sexual assault which was you know a big
deal as well okay good i'm glad you say
that yeah
yeah so i feel very very fortunate to
be in a situation that i'm in and i have
a great family that has been
um you know helpful and i've
found a counselor that's been fantastic
for me and so i feel like things are
starting to move in in a very positive
direction and i've been able to start
that healing journey and excellent so
what's your boyfriend going through
yeah i think
he knows you know the the gist of what
happened um
i haven't been able to share in detail
this story
and he's kind of asked that i i don't
share that with him until he feels ready
and i want to be respectful of that
um but also know that you know this was
a very big
um you know it was a very big situation
for both of us and um he was the first
person i called and
he was there on the scene with me
as the police were coming and
um yeah so he was very involved his
family was very involved with everything
obviously everyone went to the hospital
with me and
just felt so loved and supported and i'm
so grateful for that
but also understanding that this was
such a big impact to our relationship
um and and knowing that um you know that
there's
there's pain in the in the trauma so is
he showing signs of depression anxiety
frustration anger
is he demonstrating things are you just
proactively reaching on his behalf yeah
oh yeah so he um
he does have depression
um like he's been clinically diagnosed
with depression and he's kind of just
asked that i take it slow in terms of of
sharing this
experience and and the details of what
happened and so um whenever it kind of
comes up in conversation
um he gets really depressed and kind of
shuts down and
i can tell that there's there's hurt
there
and he hasn't you know we've briefly
talked about him pursuing
um you know
accounts like seeking a counselor and
seeking some advice and he's just like
yeah i'll get to it when i get to it
and um
knowing that
you know in my experience of trauma the
longer you let it sit the bigger it
grows
and so just wondered how i can you know
lovingly encourage him
um to to seek help
yeah man he's lucky to have you and i'll
say on behalf of
a guy who's got a wife and a mother and
a sister and a daughter
um and he's just one of your neighbors
um i'm so sorry
that you know this but i
i need to say it that that should never
happen
and i'm you're a brave courageous person
to go get the help you need and i'm
proud of you and i'm glad you're one of
my neighbors now um i'm so glad i'm glad
you're with us
um so
i'm gonna paint some broad generalities
here okay and if he's got existing
diagnostics i can't get into those right
i'd have to talk to him but
broadly speaking i've seen this play out
multiple times one of the most common
things and i'll take it out of this this
area completely and put it in a
different context um but
the same the same general idea will
apply
i've seen parents whose kid gets hurt
somewhere like in a sporting event or in
a car wreck or something
and the parents are haunted by
i should have stopped this
i should have been there that's my job i
got one job on the planet to keep my
kids safe
and
i wasn't there for whatever reason and
99.9 of the time there's no there would
have been no reason to be there would
have been insane for you to be there but
that's where our heads go right
and so
using that example and swinging it back
if he's like most boyfriends
rightly or wrongly there's this overly
i've got my duty is to protect and like
that kind of stuff right even though you
you could possibly beat him up in a fist
fight that's it's not about strength and
muscles it's more about role and
disposition
and
i should have been there i should have
kept her safe what i couldn't even i
can't even right and there's these
moments these traumas these tragedies
that happen
that make us feel so small
and really
throw the curtains back like you know
it's like just ripping the covers off
the bed
we don't have control of much of
anything
we're flying blind in this deal right
the woman i love can be doing something
as benign as taking somebody from ihop
over to a concert hall and then this bad
thing can happen to a nat you know what
i mean it makes us feel small and
powerless
and some of us when we feel small and
powerless we try to grab power
everywhere we can right i'm gonna
join a crossfit gym and crush it and
kill it and listen to pantera and slayer
and this will never happen again
and then often
the other happens
i just fold up and i can't talk about it
i want to hear it i can't hear it my
body reacts overreacts to the point it
swamps my system i can't do anything
so here's a the the
the powerless truth on your part is this
you can't make him do anything
and that's right
for a woman who lost control
who is gonna try to i want you to watch
this in yourself
you're going to have a tendency to
grab control where you can have it
because somebody stole it from you
okay
and is that am i am i onto something
with you
totally okay excellent calendar this
you'd be on time you'd be on like you'll
find yourself doing that and one of part
of your trauma healing will be
being able to hey remember what happened
talk about it without your body
re-experiencing it that's the big one
but also you'll be able to contextualize
it
a bad thing happened to me for little to
no reason
and yet i'm gonna go about my day and
learn how to be graceful and learn how
to roll my eyes and learn how to laugh
again learn how to sleep again right to
teach my body that it doesn't have to be
on 24 7. that thing happened and
statistically speaking it's never going
to happen again but it did and you hear
him saying right that's part of the
journey
you can't make him do that and so here's
what the what i would suggest is one or
two gifts you have
you're seeing somebody right now in for
mental health care
i would invite him i would let him know
i really would like you to come to this
with me
you don't have to say anything
you were part of my life i want you to
be a part of my future and so i want you
to be a part of my healing not make this
about him but this is about you because
you're the only one that you can deal
with you're the only one that you can
control so invite him to this and i
would let your therapist know i want him
to come i need to tell him this story as
part of my healing i need him to be a
part of this with me and he's unable to
hear it right now and so i want him to
be a part of this process and what
you'll hear is y'all will have to
negotiate back and forth for a season
um
as part of my healing i need you to tell
you what so you'll know fully know me
and he's going to say a part of my
healing as you i need you to be quiet
and you're going to have to navigate
negotiate that together as you move
forward having a counselor do that with
you is really helpful
um not every relationship needs that
this one sounds like it does okay and
that's a good thing for you guys because
what you're doing is you're learning a
new language on how to have hard
conversations with each other how to be
graceful with each other and then both
of you need to have
that courage that you have right now he
needs to be courageous and also you need
to respect his boundaries and there goes
the circle right what you don't want to
have happen which i see happen all the
time in this situation
is you guys start comparing trauma and
you start comparing grief
he's gonna have something happen he's
gonna get covered he's gonna lose a like
a part-time job he's gonna have
something
and he's going to get down about it and
you're going to think oh yeah you want
to know what bad is
right
and your body's going to turn him into
the bad guy
or
you're going to start comparing grief
you're going to start thinking things
like good god i'm the one this happened
to and even i'm moving on
and he's gonna be stuck in it and he's
gonna be saying
i think you're psychotic i think you're
a robot i think you've got problems if
you're already working on your heal
right so you're gonna start comparing
grief you'll have to be really
intentioned about not doing that owning
each other's grief and owning the fact
that y'all are going to heal differently
and here's the kicker
you all both got to get up and make your
bed you both got to get up and go to
work you both got to get up and do
things that are going to keep you all
well does that make sense you both got
to go back to church you both got to do
those things that are going to keep you
well and healthy and so i think that can
start with him coming coming back to
coming to therapy with you not coming
back going to it and here's one other
thing you've heard me say this a million
times and i'll say it a million times
more
i would love for you all to you can't
have these conversations sometimes with
someone who's struggling with depression
the conversation overwhelms the systems
but writing it doesn't
and if you all kept a
letters journal to each other that
you'll share i'm gonna write what i'm
feeling right now i'm gonna hand it to
you you can read it on your own time in
your own place when you feel safe and
you owe me something back
even if it's i can't even right now or
this is so hard for me to even read it
overwhelms me i'm not going to write
anything back today that's fine then
we're still we're still communicating
and slowly but surely might not be able
to speak in the same room with you and
see you and remember back to the
flashing lights and you in the hospital
but i can write it
and we're going to slowly communicate
back and forth that way in this journal
maybe 10 years from now 20 years from
now 50 years from now be something your
grandkids read it'll be worth its weight
in gold does that sound like something
y'all can do
yeah that definitely sounds um
reasonable for us
um i think that's i think i think that's
fantastic and i think those two things
will get you all down the road
there may come a moment where you say i
can't move forward with us and this
happened um with somebody close to me
i can't move forward unless we sit down
and have this hard conversation
you tell me when but it has to happen it
has to happen soon
um or i am taking that as you choosing
to not be in relationship with me
and if he can't hear about it then and
you tell him this is a part of being in
relationship with me is
processing this trauma together
then he has to go get the help he needs
so that he can have that conversation
with you or by not getting help he's
choosing
out of the relationship
and that's going to be hard for
everybody okay let's start with the
first two first with the journal and
with inviting him to therapy with you to
your counseling for your challenges for
your healing not for his for yours
and see if he'll be a part of that